So far, we are hearing a lot about this BCMA bispecifics targeting specifically the BCMA
antigen. I think this is getting very complicated in terms of the treating physician. Which one to
choose? How to choose? How long we should treat? What to deal with the toxicities? Is it the right
fit for this patient or not? And it's going to get confusing again and again, year and year,
and we will still have this debate going on for the next five years.
So my topic is to talk about the linvoseltamab, which is relatively new bispecific compared to
teclistamab and l-renatamab. So they came a little late in this game. The same way that we have a
daratumumab, we have an isotuximab. So we will talk about its main data that how this came into
present, like, you know, in the treating patients with linvoseltamab, what leads to
CFD-approved.
And then we can talk about what's the future promising things, what we can do with this drug.
So after my disclosure, so I'm going to go to this linker MM1 study. This is FDA-approved,
standard of care, and we are using this in our clinical practice. So what is unique about this
drug is the step-up dosing. So typically you go with the teclistamab and l-renatamab, they have a
specific set of protocols, at least in our practices and some others. Very few institutions
are doing outpatient bispecifics. So it's going to be a little bit more complicated, but I think it's
going to be a little bit more complicated. So I'm going to go to this linker MM1 study. This is FDA-approved,
standard of care, and we are using this in our clinical practice. So what is unique about this drug is the
step-up dosing. So we are using the teclistamab and l-renatamab, they have a specific set of protocols,
but it's mainly go for the inpatient bispecific timeline. You watch for observations, go from
there. So here it's very predictable. So patients are admitted to the hospital for only two doses,
one week apart, and it's a 24-hour observation, very predictable. 11 to 14 hours is the time for
the CRS, which makes us kind of appealing for some people who are in the community,
and they want to use the bispecifics. So they want something like a predictability. So that's where
the important thing come up about this. The next slide, please.
Okay, so what we're looking at is this cohort of patients who are heavily pre-treated,
at least the five lines of therapy. High-risk biology was present in 82% of the patients,
and especially 39% have on high-risk cytogenetics and 16% with EMT.
And the way the dosing has been done, that it's weekly given from week three to week 12,
which is 200 milligram, and after that, we go for every other week from 14 to 23 weeks,
and then those patients who achieve VGPR,
they were getting 200 milligram Q4 weekly, which is kind of easy schedule for the patients who've
been going through the bispecifics. Now, if you look at the responses,
the objective response rates for the single-agent limbo was 71%. CRs go beyond more than 50%,
and the median overall survival is 31.4 months. And these are the patients who are
heavily pre-treated, and MRD negativity in patients who achieved the CR was quite significant,
around 95%. So that's a lot of patients who are heavily pre-treated, and MRD negativity in patients
who achieved the CR was quite significant, around 94%. And pentadefractary, you can see he's here
around 68%. Now, on the right side, if you look at it, who are those patients who are getting the
most benefits? So first of all, you can dissect them from this graph. Patients who have heavy
burden disease, these are the ones whose responses are getting a little lesser compared to the
patients who have a less burdened disease. And when we enroll patients in the clinical trials,
you look for the fit patients. And one of the biggest arguments we get,
like, you know, these patients, and in the real-world setting, there are two different
populations. Sometimes you need an urgency of the treatment, start the treatment sooner.
It depends on the disease burden, aggressiveness of the disease. So if you keep that in mind,
it's still the objective responses go, you know, if you have a bulky disease, around 50%.
And also, we were looking for the soluble BCMA levels, higher the level, more aggressive biology,
and the lesser responses. But otherwise, if you combine the whole cohort, the responses are quite
significant. Now, this is another concern always about the bispecifics. How are we going to manage
the CRS and those toxicities? So we learned a lot from earlier bispecific studies, like how these
CRS have been managed. And we've been getting better and better about these things and combining
the bispecific, combining the imates of monoclonal antibodies. But if you look at it, especially in
the linker MM1 study, and in some other studies too, say when patients are going to the less
frequent dosing, the rates of complications are starting to get less and less. CRS rates are quite
predictable in the first two doses. But you know, after four months, and beyond that, you can see
that the graphs are dramatically going down and the rates of complications are also lesser. Now,
the neutropenia is very much dose dependent. When in the study, when we use the dose 50 milligram,
and then jump to 200 milligrams, our neutropenia rates did go higher. But that is also being
expected in the bispecific therapies. But if you look at it overall, grade three and grade four
toxicities are quite lesser compared to any grade toxicities.
Now, although we do not like the cross trial comparisons, but sometimes for a treating
physician and for the patients, it's important to understand what's the rates of CRS, what's the
rates of complications we see. Here we have all three bispecifics, like a teclistamab, linvo and
talquitamab, which are BCMA bispecifics. You can see their CRS rates and compare them. Grade three
CRS is quite relatively uncommon compared in all three CRS complications, but any grade CRS is kind
of still high. Responses rates are pretty comparable. All three drugs you are seeing
responses between 60 to 70%. And same thing, you know, for the talquitamab,
you're seeing around 70%. So it's very comparable compared to other bispecific therapies. Now,
this is something that I already been discussed. So I'm just going to shed a light here that there's
a lot of combinations people are trying to work on in the clinical trials, combining the image,
monoclonal antibody, two bispecifics together, understanding the responses. And in the future,
we will know how these combinations usually will work. Now, I'm going to highlight this
CoSTEM study where linvoseltamab is combined with another bispecific,
which is a co-stimulatory molecule, combining it with the CD38 target. So you can, this trial is
been enrolling the patients who've been on this study with the linvoseltamab.
Now, again, you can see the deep responses, and it's been considered as an alternative for
our patients as well, who really need a BCMA bispecific therapy with two doses required,
the hospitalizations pretty comparable to consistent within prior studies with other
bispecifics. Now, this is where this study with this drug has been going. So it's been
everywhere. Now you can see this graph we run in medical schools and keep learning that relapsed
refractory, smoldering myeloma, there are many trials that are targeting the BCMA, upfront study,
relapse setting, different novel combinations. And I think this is an unmet need to understand
how these bispecifics actually work. So we've been seeing data, MAGISTEC-3 data, earlier
incorporation of bispecifics. Many trials are going on in an upfront setting, how we can incorporate
the bispecifics. Dr. Ganesh Narayanan:
Yes. But I think there is still unmet need for patients who have a very aggressive biology,
and they do not respond no matter what we do. And whether the early incorporation of these agents
with the novel combinations would be the game changer, we don't know. But I think in the next
five years, we're going to learn a lot about how we sequence these bispecifics, when to use CAR-T,
when to use bispecifics, should we use CAR-T first, bispecifics later, bispecifics first,
CAR-T later. So with that, I'm going to end my presentation. Thank you.
Subtitles by the Amara.org community